michael irvin the playmaker
hall-of-famer NFL Network analyst he won
three Super Bowls with the Cowboys and
he joins us on behalf of frito-lay
launching its first ever football themed
portfolio campaign in preparation for
one of the busiest periods of the year
so you have brands like Frito Lays
Tostitos Doritos Cheetos and Michael
Deion Sanders Tony Gonzalez Terry
Bradshaw will bring the campaign to life
a new TV commercial airing during the
college bowl games and the NFL playoffs
good morning Irv how are you Dave hey
hey I'm happy now DP because you know
what hearing your voice that's the good
luck charm I know everything is going to
be working out now just great deep I
love your buddy I didn't hear your voice
be ready for crunch time campaign
we're Frito Lays I get to hear your
voice before the real crunch time
Jane between balancing the physicals I
know all will be fine now DP how're you
doing buddy I'm doing great what makes
you nervous about the Cowboys against
the Eagles this weekend have you seen
them play this year yes but did they
figure out anything last week that they
can take into this game with the Eagles
yes they did and and I don't know why
they needed last week to figure it out
you know you saw about probably around
sistex game of the season after they
went in that first kid that a
three-games kid after they started
three-and-oh people started talking
about well maybe is now going to be
Mourdock team instead of Zeke's team and
they'll go still start winning with the
past I knew I knew that was a mistake
I knew I was like no you cannot do that
the top teams now bigger 49ers the
Ravens these are all run first teams
even though we try to turn this lead
into a pass Hockey League the teams that
run the ball well are the teams that are
winning and every time that that throws
ball under 25 times he's nine and oh the
other day he threw the ball 23 times
they had to 100 yard rushers I
leave I believe DP that they have
figured it out now
it's just a matter of doing it each and
every week because if they could do it
each and every week they can have an
epic to start run too deep in this rail
I thought they were a Superbowl caliber
team to start the year and I really
debated whether I was going to take them
or the Eagles to go to the Super Bowl
they've both underachieve greatly but I
still you know the Eagles are banged up
the Cowboys aren't they're banged up a
little bit at linebacker but you know
I'm not sold on the secondary but they
have a offensive line they got skilled
position guys and I still think that
they can they can do some damage
although if they do win the East and
then the Niners come to town that could
end quickly here but I talked to Troy
Aikman about this and I said how far do
they need to go that you satisfy Jerry
Jones is it Super Bowl or bust before
changes are made and FC title game or
bust what do you think yeah I think you
cannot you have to at least get to a NFC
title game you know what I mean you have
to get there and then we play a good
game I visit the Super Bowl and that's
great and great but you have to at least
get deep into the playoffs it's been
such a long time before that star has
been in that light upon a game that size
and Jerry you know we all know he's not
getting any younger and he wants to see
that star put on the top of the tree at
least one more time before time takes
them on to eternity so you have to make
sure and you know I you know I love
coach Garrett you know he was my backup
quarterback and I worked many days with
him on the football field so I'm hoping
they get it together I'm hoping and I
Scott I get to sit down with Ezekiel
earlier today I'm hoping to hear say
these guys are going to rally to bring
their best out because their coach means
that much to them yes they want to win a
Super Bowl but anytime you can bring
more things to put in your belly to make
you more hungry for like gee I want to
keep my coach's job being that all helps
to talking to playmaker Michael Irvin
joining us Dan Patrick show I mentioned
this about 15 minutes ago
I was waiting for the backlash with
Lamar Jackson and it's already started
because people want to know is this
sustainable what's gonna happen in the
postseason when a team gets a chance to
gear up for him you know is this a
one-year wonder and and I said why why
can't we just enjoy what we're seeing
people want to be right they want to
tell you I told you so I told you Baker
Mayfield shouldn't have been the number
one pick or I told you you know Lamar
Jackson couldn't do this forever
I don't know other than win now in the
NFL win now and if it means I use Lamar
Jackson and we win now and he's out of
the league in five years because of
health reasons he's not going to change
that he wants to win now as well I'm
surprised that people are there they're
waiting for Lamar Jackson to fail now
yeah that's what we do then that's
really what we do in this country you
know we want to fill you up on my
college this is incredible we never saw
it before
oh my god I can't wait let's start
seeing it fall now because we want to
see both sides of it you want to see it
climb because that's a great story but
once it's on top of the mountains we
tell all those stories you want to see a
fall because you get more great stories
even on the fall the reality is you're
limiting him we are limiting him you
know Lamar Jackson is winning right now
using his legs and doing great things in
the run game but he still leads the
league in touchdown passes he leads the
league so we're acting as if he can't
continue to grow and maybe he stopped
running as much as he runs now or start
running as violently and as dangerously
as he runs now and he fits in the pocket
a little bit more later but by saying oh
he won't make it five years is saying
he's only going to play one way we watch
the greatest quarterback of all time
all games grow we watch when they want
intent went into England was running the
ball in defense and Tom just managed the
game and then up to those old 7 seasons
where Tom had the best offense in the
world and he was throwing the ball all
over the field now it's kind of going
back to the other side
where they're trying to win with peaches
and
and running the ball again give him an
opportunity to grow this is a smart kid
he played he loves the game and more
important in all of that every party
that plays with them love playing with
him I saw this when he was 10 years old
in in in Pompano high in Pompano playing
Little League football he's doing the
same thing is right now I got one team
that's under the radar I think this team
is going to go to the Super Bowl
representing the AFC Kansas City Chiefs
yeah yeah yeah I don't know if I can go
there with it I like I like Baltimore I
like what they're doing I like the way
that they play together I like the way
that offense serves that defense see
that's not what you get in Kansas City
Kansas City the offense doesn't serve
the defense they got a big playoff
you're right Kansas City they're trying
to score fast which puts that defense
back on the field but more Jackson those
guys can hold on to the ball forever let
the defense rest
and so the often serves the defense
where it doesn't do that necessarily in
Kansas City but on the other hand if
Kansas City gets up early gotta put
Lamar and Baltimore in a situation that
I think it's tough for them which is in
combat mode so I understand what you're
saying but I still like Baltimore over
Kansas City what about green bang you
sold on Green Bay Oh God I'm sold on the
wild card and wild card is ain't Iran
Rodgers Aaron Rodgers is no matter what
when I officially put them in no matter
what the situation is as long as you
have him you got a chance because the
game is going to remain closed and he'll
give you a chance to make a play to win
a game late in the game cuz that's what
he does great I'm at the floor he's the
luckiest man in the world everybody was
talking early on about the arguing of
between him and there he's not arguing
with Aaron Rodgers Matt Lafleur is like
a backpack
his own Aaron Rodgers back he just left
so he's like thank you for this this is
the greatest ride in the world
just call the plate and get out of the
way arise as the rest that's all he has
to do we like to talk about the Pro Bowl
snubs more than we do
who made the Pro Bowl in the NFC Russell
Wilson Drew Brees and Aaron Rodgers are
your quarterbacks did dak Prescott get
snubbed or did Kirk Cousins get snubbed
well you're the leading passer and right
now there's a quarterback so I say that
got snob in that sense and he's been
leading enansal for quite a stretch of
the season he's played in every game but
who you taking out though Mike okay I
know I don't everybody just mad about
this but I would take out Zulu Brees
Drew Brees didn't play the whole season
and when his backup was in the game they
still won every game 19 Drew Brees is
not great he is absolutely great and any
congratulations to him on getting the
touchdown record they did you see that
to defeat is what I was talking about
the other day I just I love I love Tom
Brady so much Tom Brady did you see the
tweet when he congratulated Drew Brees
but you could tell it was in him I
congratulate you
you got all these and all of these rings
and you still want to take this last one
from this man
it's amazing the competitor that he is
even at this age man I mean young kids
you got to see that you got to adore
that anything you got to strive to be
that my great to talk to hope to see you
at the Super Bowl
yes sir dance it's crunch time baby
ready for crunch time let's lock it in
and get ready for this good bowl season
and play all season
that's what crunch time is about and you
could see the TV commercial with Terry
Bradshaw Tony Gonzalez and Deion Sanders
and of course Michael Irvin during the
bowl season and the end of
playoffs Thank You Irv great to talk to
you always great talk to you buddy good
good luck coming all right Michael Irvin
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]